over to downtown to the county
administration building where candace
charles is standing by
that's right christian good afternoon
folks this door is locked and the sign
here says that the building is temporary
closed
employees have told me earlier today
that there was a police search here this
morning inside is the office of robert
tellis and rita reid
recently won tell a position as county
administrator i spoke with her husband
this morning he said her phone was
confiscated during a police search
records and emails were also looked
through about an hour ago employees were
asked to go home some of them spoke with
me off camera saying they were shocked
but that they did see telus driving in a
vehicle that looked similar to the one
connected to jeff german's death now
they did reach out to the county and
they said at this time quote they do not
have a comment of course this is a
developing story so stick with us 8 news
now for the latest for now live from the
county administrator building on candice
charles 8 news now our